syndicaliste québécois fernand des eaux
est décédé à l'âge de 93 ans fernande
house est impliqué pendant plus de 40
ans dans le mouvement syndical
principalement est la ftq avec son
complice louis laberge
ensemble ils ont mené de nombreux
combats pour les travailleurs notamment
lors du lock out à la presse en 1971
avec le front commun intersyndical de 72
et lors de la grève de laâyoune a été de
374 avec nous ce soir andré leclerc
biographe de fernando ou bonsoir
monsieur leclerc biographe de fernanda
ou deux en fait deux tombant à cette
biographie que vous avez écrit dans les
dernières années ça fait à peu près 700
pages c'est dire combien il est un géant
vraiment dans le monde syndical
une légende du monde syndical comment
décrivez nous un peu fernandez
d'abord c'est un homme qui par sa
prestance son élocution impressionné
beaucoup et plusieurs croyaient qu'il
était d'origine un peu plus ou moins
bourgeoise qu'il avait étudié des
grandes études en fait il avait été
élevé il est né dans le faubourg à
m'lasse way et il avait été élevé par
une mère célibataire mère monoparentale
c'est une famille monoparentale sa mère
était couturière travaillait dans
l'industrie du vêtement
elle a eu des pensionnaires pour arriver
à élever ses enfants et lui à force de
bras parce qu'il aimait les études il
payait ses études puis l'a réussi aller
à l'université en relations
industrielles et au sortir de ses études
il a voulu me faire syndicales et
souhaité son choix c'était clair même si
la plupart de ses collègues se diriger
du côté patronal lui était attiré par le
monde syndical et il a développé le
syndicalisme québécois tel qu'on le
connaît quand il y est arrivé il a
participé à son évolution
mais peu à peu il est pris de plus en
plus de place à l'intérieur du mouvement
il ya commencé sa carrière syndicale en
mais dès les années 50 4,55 il était
déjà secrétaire du conseil du travail de
montréal
tous les syndicats nord américains et
internationaux de la région de montréal
et il a participé aussi à la fusion
entre les grands syndicats de métier les
syndicats industriels et il était là
lors de la création de la ftq et la
fédération des travailleurs du québec
quand on regarde l'histoire de la ftq on
pense à louis laberge
on pense à fernande et où cette histoire
là s'est écrite avec louis laberge avec
fernando ils ont été des complices
improbable au départ improbable parce
qu'ils étaient même concurrents ben oui
et ils ont été candidats au moment de la
mort du premier président de la ftq
ranger provost ils ont été tous les deux
candidats à sa succession est un conseil
général qui a dû trancher pour l'intérim
jusqu'aux votre congrès suivant et louis
laberge a remporté la mise par une voix
ah oui et non et fernand représente un
peu le plus progressé + plus
nationaliste souci des syndicats alors
que la berge était plus vu un peu comme
le représentant de la plus conservatrice
mais ils se sont retrouvés ensemble à la
direction de la ftq
à partir du moment où fernand est devenu
secrétaire général et à partir de 1969
ils ont formé un tandem très très
solidaire laberge a évolué beaucoup
il rejoint beaucoup des positions de
fernando ou par exemple sur la question
nationale sur la question du français et
fernand d'ailleurs a été le grand grand
instigateur de toutes les batailles sur
le français langue de travail au québec
sylvie vraiment avec d'autres bien sûr
bien sûr qu'ils aient fait en sorte que
les français prennent sa place dans le
monde du travail et au moment où il
était nommé qu'une été élu secrétaire
général de la ftq en 1969 au même
congrès a été débattue pour la première
fois une politique de la langue alors qu
jusque là la ftq était restée assez
discrète sur ces questions là et là on a
affirmé qu'il fallait vraiment une
politique de la langue globale au québec
il fallait que la loi garantisse le
droit de travailler en français et
s'affirmant le défendrai depuis
longtemps mais louis la rejoint et là
dessus et au congrès de 69
il ya eu cette politique adoptée et on
retrouve dans cette politique de la
langue adoptée par la ftq de grands
éléments de la loi 101 qu'allait adopter
plus tard le gouvernement du parti
québécois
parlez nous un peu du fonds de
solidarité ftq il est à l'origine du
ferry avec louis laberge bien sûr et
jacques parizeau et j'en réalise ont eu
beaucoup de feintes de syndicalistes
aussi des syndicats affiliés à la ftq
parce que la ftq
sans ces syndicats ça n'existe pas la
ftq ce regroupement de syndicats des
syndicats qui ont une grande autonomie
qui ont un fonctionnement un mode de
fonctionnement total mais la grande
force des la berge de ou et dans la
construction du fonds solidarité
c'est ça aussi leur grande force ça a
été de rallier tous ces syndicats de les
faire travailler ensemble de les unifier
et de développer
un rapport de force avec avec les forces
politiques et les forces économiques du
québec qui a permis à la ftq de devenir
un grand acteur social et économique et
économique
oui parce que fonds solidarité la ftq
depuis pendant toute la durée des années
soixante dix a été confrontée à
plusieurs fermetures d usines et
tentative de relance des entreprises
on pense à l'expérience de tricot fil wi
fi revendre à ou pas d'ailleurs a été
très très impliqué dans cette expérience
il a subi ce début jusqu'à la fin et on
en a tiré cette conclusion qu'il fallait
pas laisser un groupe d'hommes et de
femmes auraient acheté du marché du
travail par une part de 10 entreprises
qui ne sont ne se sont pas rénovés noms
n'ont pas fait les efforts de
modernisation nécessaire
on doit laisser à ces personnes seules
le tout la recharge d'une relance et
c'est pourquoi il faisait il fallait se
donner des moyens financiers c'est là
qu'est né en s'inspirant des expériences
d'expérience scandinave ans et en
s'inspirant de d'un projet de société
social démocrate
cette idée d'un fonds de solidarité un
fonds d investissement monsieur leclerc
va être passionnant ça on pourrait
parler très longtemps mais la suite est
dans ses livres pour se les gens qui
veulent en savoir davantage sur ce grand
homme du québec fernandez ou merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci et au
revoir